okay so King Miss Harrison House of the
Dragon is actually one of the most
complicated characters in the show
though on the surface he seems like a
king who simply seeks peace there's far
more going on with him during the happy
sad confused podcast Paddy considine
discussed his betrayal of the king in
depth and I think it was a completely
eye-opening interview that went into
what really motivated the character
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down what was said and how it
makes viserys even more interesting and
there will be full spoilers for what
happens to the king so if you haven't
seen episode 8 of House of the Dragon
then I recommend that you turn off now
hit the thumbs up button to give us your
favor and pledge allegiance to our house
by hitting subscribe by the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our King viserys video now in order to
understand the secret adversar has
carried I think we have to hear it from
the man himself to give some context to
this he's talking about what he took
from the King and also a deleted scene
that had his reaction to her death in
the immediate aftermath of it you've
been very kind in talking about the
director and the creators and the
writers and and your fellow actors
um and I I want to get the pronunciation
of her her name right Sean Brooke is
that how you pronounced her name yeah
yeah
um who you've been saying like that's
the key to the character for you is the
loss of that character that that really
casts a shadow and down to his dying
breath
um yeah and that and that was clear to
you from from the start this was going
to be
um the inciting incident or the the
incident that would really just cast The
Shadow over the rest of his life
yeah I understood what that event did to
him I had an idea what it did to him
um but
uh um but because you you take on a
character and and I'm talking about
acting so nothing pretentious you go on
a journey and because I've directed as
well when I'm when I direct I'm very
open to things moving you know um like
the first film I wrote directed
Tyrannosaur it was very it was scripted
it wasn't improvised film it was
scripted and they stuck to the script
but ideas came and went in it new
avenues opened as we were making it and
I was never afraid to explore those
possibilities
um and and I think I'm like that as an
actor as well particularly when you're
living with a character for a really
long period of time so
you know what I'm saying is you're
receptive I'm very receptive to things
and people and events so when I knew
that the death of Emma would devastate
viserys but until we shot it and I
worked with Sean for what was just a few
days and I think what determined it was
because what we shot was ten times more
brutal than what you saw and he was ten
times more devastated than what you saw
I mean he was inconsolable he was
absolutely destroyed
um
and
there was a scene that didn't make the
cut where I'm sitting on the bed there's
blood on the bed and I've got the dagger
and one of the maesters brings
I don't know if he brings bail on to me
and I can't even look at him oh I think
the thing was he comes to tell me that
actually Balon hasn't lived
and so viserys was hit with this double
whack of Devastation of his wife
and then the kid
you know his son and then then there was
this sense of like her you know like
that cruel twist of fate of like I'm not
surprised you know I'm not surprised
resignation was just like amused
resignation yeah yeah yeah and they cut
it and and probably rightly so because
it just puts them to the funeral pyre
but and that's probably the right choice
really but it was just the impact of
those scenes the amount of motion that
we put into it and the amount of effort
and emotion that Sean put into it
there was such long hard days filming
and she left such an impression with her
work even in the more tender scenes that
I I I just she left a kind of imprint
everywhere and she left this impression
on me and it just changed the pulse of
how I played the character I just went
this is it this is the thing that this
man carries for the rest of his life and
this is the thing that he can't get over
and my secret then became
you know when she's burning it's like
I I don't want to live anymore
um so when he starts to he's starting to
get these injuries from the throne and
he's starting to get this kind of you
know the stuff on his back the
blistering on his back
when it starts to develop into something
else he doesn't care because right yeah
if you if you look at the story he
doesn't ask the maesters for a cure he's
not scared he's not going to help me my
arm's falling off it's everybody else
going let's try the leeches let's try
this or there's an old technique you
know he's not he's just silently
accepting his face
by way of
punishment
for what he put his wife through in
those final moments and
and that's how those that those days of
shown
changed the way that I went about the
currency because secretly I just went
this is a love story and one day he'll
be reunited so that explains the real
tragedy of viserys and then he died
along with his wife I love the section
about him refusing to accept any healing
because he has no interest in being
saved and just wants to be with his love
him constantly thinking of her is also
something that we see throughout the
series too and there are a number of
indicators towards this secret firstly
viserys clearly cares more about
rhaenyra than he does the rest of his
family he constantly downplays them and
talks about how she's his daughter and
definitely the favorite when we see
aegon riding out to his coronation he
finds it hard to believe his father
named him the air because he didn't
think he cared about him he of course
also doesn't change the error at any
point even in the wake of having a son
men were seen as the ones that should
lead but him still holding his daughter
as the heir shows that he didn't want to
hand power over to Alison's side it also
cements the kind of relationship that
they had and raniera being Emma's
daughter Amazon the idea that this is
who he viewed as being his true wife in
the most epic walk of all time viserys
hobbles to the iron throne in order to
claim that luceris will remain the heir
of driftmark when it came to Eamon
getting his eye slashed out he didn't
give a f but he's willing to do this
just to protect his daughter and also
her children at this point viserys was
heavily medicated with milk of the poppy
but he even turned this down from Otto
Just to carry this out the character
would have been in so much pain but he
put himself through that in order to set
on the throne even earlier in the season
when he's alone in his room and the rats
are closing in he also plays with a ring
before slipping it onto his finger we
get a brief look at this and it has the
house of Aaron sigil on it this is the
house that Emma comes from and the ring
would have belonged to her when she was
alive him kissing this shows he hasn't
let go and still thinks about her when
he's alone at night episode 9 even
showed that he and Alison didn't sleep
in the same room as when she's told of
his dad she's in her own bed the book
goes into detail on this and Alison
slept in the Queen's chamber for most of
their marriage Razzy and Emma would
share the same room on top of this a
drift Mark when going to bed viserys
calls Alice and Emma I'm going to bed
this shows that he's still living in
this moment where he's with her and he's
literally now rotting away from the
inside without having her love viserys's
love clearly lasts from this point
onwards all the way to his final few
moments as well and when discussing his
death Paddy said this so by the final
scene
but he's lying on the bed
and all I had in my head was that he
reaches up and touches her face
and then he I improvised that moment
where I say my love and the beautiful
thing as well about that episode was
that they just picked up every Nuance
you you give good work to people and
they don't see it they don't see the
little moments they don't see the crown
falling off the head and use it you know
they they stop and go again whereas the
accidents are where beautiful things
happen and Peter allowed for these
things to happen and not only that
um put them in put these little nuances
in put those moments in and and I was
really grateful because you know a lot
of your performance too depends on the
work of everybody else and the choices
they make in the edit and I can say with
my hand on my heart that I thought the
choices they made were fantastic so now
we know this all makes sense as to why
viserys's Ark went the way it did in the
source material he was a much jollier
character and didn't carry the disease
that he has in the show here though it's
very much his soul riding away
manifesting physically on the surface he
doesn't care about losing everything as
to him he doesn't really have anything
left he still sit in his room thinking
of his deceased wife at night and in his
final moments reaches out to Emma
although this exchange is between him
and Alison he thinks it's rhaenyra and
therefore it actually adds more way to
him reaching out to her instead and now
point is he panicking and asking to see
Alison for the last time because in his
mind he's with the people that matter he
believes he's with renira and he starts
to see Emma as he goes which to him is
who his true family is gives so much
more to what Paddy does with the
character I can't wait to re-watch the
season with this in mind obviously happy
sad confused helped me massively when it
came to making the video and it's such a
good podcast that I definitely think you
should check out I just want to do a
really quick plug for this amazing shirt
we're selling at Zero edition on it
you'll see the depiction of the painted
table which outlines the entirety of
Westeros but wait there's more if you
use the augmented reality app on your
phone then guess what happens an AR
Dragon comes in and burns up the entire
map to reveal more details this brings
out new things like names terrain and
you've got a [ __ ] Dragon floating
around saying fire
now the [ __ ] is selling like dracara's
cakes so if you want some cool clothing
and to celebrate that A Game of Thrones
prequel save the show then this is the
shirt for you such a cool combo with the
AR app as well that makes this one of a
kind link to it is in the description
and pin comments so support the channel
and get some awesome merch you son of a
[ __ ] you want something else to watch
make sure you check out our breakdown of
raniera which will be linked on screen
right now we go about everything you
need to know about the character
including her part in the show and where
things will be going if we look at the
book if not then thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor and see
you next time take care peace